c'est un mot français qui vient du latin
veut salir et hrw au tai chi et rebondir
[Musique]
c'est un mot que les métallurgistes
laisser les sous-mariniers emploi tous
les jours c'est à dire qu'un métal garde
sa structure aux reprend sa structure
quelles que soient les coûts les
pressions du milieu donc c'est un mot
français très peu employée en france
jusqu'à maintenant mais très couramment
employées dans le langage quotidien dans
les pays anglo saxons iriez-vous que
c'est une résiliente
anne hidalgo vous êtes fait d'un métal
qui résiste aux chocs je m'inscris
complètement dans ce que dit boris
cyrulnik
d'ailleurs j'ai je les rencontre et j'ai
eu la chance de beaucoup
lire aussi tous ses livres oui je pense
que il le dit très clairement il faut
être soi même il faut avoir des
convictions évidemment ne pas vivre en
autarcie ou fermée aux autres il faut
accepter de se laisser aussi influencé
changé par les autres heureusement parce
que nous sommes des êtres sociaux et on
est tous interdépendants sans les autres
on n'est rien et en même temps il faut
être soi-même et savoir aussi résisté à
la violence des paroles à l'agressivité
et à la violence tout court savoir
résister aussi à des espèces
d'emportement d'emballement qui sont
quand même très dangereux où il faut
toujours quand même quelques voix qui a
peut-être je n'ai pas la solidité qui
est la mienne aujourd'hui je la puise
dans mes racines dans ma famille dans
mon histoire et puis je suis quelqu'un
qui aime profondément la vie
profondément les changes avec les autres
c'est tout ça qui fait une résilience
donc être résilience et accepter la vie
et en même temps pose est toujours
toujours les éléments de valeur et
d'essayer fait en tout cas ce que
j'essaie de faire d'aligner mes valeurs
avec avec
ma vie est aussi dans la rencontre avec
les autres parce que je leur dis tout
seul on est strictement rien
[Musique]